erster juni 2009 10
kurz vor mitternacht weiter lück
geraucht noch eine zigarette
er ahnt nicht dass ein neonazi ihn in
new york
dann ein schuss
aus nächster nähe trifft eine kugel
weiter lüpkes kopf
ich war fassungslos und bin in tränen
ausgebrochen
der mutmaßliche mörder der hessische
neonazi stefan ernst so sieht es die
bundesanwaltschaft für die ermittler ein
mord über monate geplant
der fall gilt als erster rechtsextremer
mord an einem politiker in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik
deutschland
wie konnte es zum mord an walter lück
gekommen familienvater cdu-politiker und
kasseler regierungspräsident wir werden
hunderte seiten ermittlungsakten aus
zeugenbefragungen und interne dokumente
wir sind auf der spur des mutmaßlichen
täters und seines opfers
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wenn man die geschichte von stefan ernst
und seinem opfer weiter lübke
recherchiert stößt man unweigerlich auf
dieses video werden werden sie werde
sich das land verlassen würden einmal im
jahr 2019 kursiert das über drei jahre
alte linie wieder in den sozialen
netzwerken erika steinbach mittlerweile
im afg umfeld aktiv verweist auf das
video
was folgt ist neuer hass gegen walter
lübke ich war für mich völlig
unvermittelt das plötzlich dieses video
wieder auftauchte und das hat ja auch
unter anderem erika steinbach auf ihre
facebook- oder twitter-account nochmal
verbreitet dadurch jetzt nochmal eine
besondere dynamik gekriegt und erst
später gab es wohl auch neue drohungen
mails auch stefan ernst teilt das video
er schreibt eine sms an seine mutter
hallo mama schau dir das an
da siehst du wie weit sich dieser
abschaum von volksvertretern von uns
entfernt hat ein rückblick was genau
geschah an dem abend an dem das video
entstand vierzehnter oktober 2015
regierungspräsident walter lübcke lädt
zur bürgerversammlung in lohfelden soll
in einem leerstehenden gartencenter eine
flüchtlingsunterkunft entstehen lücke
will informieren aufklären und ängste
nehmen
zur versammlung kommen über 800 gäste
darunter auch rechtsextremisten die das
heim verhindern wollen
ich habe das genau so wahrgenommen dass
es einige leute im saal gab die bewusst
stören wollten
die drp vor allem aus der ersten reihe
ständig unterbrochen haben mit
volksverräter start
hau ab und so weiter die stimmung im
saal ist aufgeheizt
unter den anwesenden lüpkes späterer
mutmaßlicher mörder stefan ernst
er hat einen begleiter bei sich marcus h
er ist es der das video noch am abend
bei youtube hochlädt
dort bricht daraufhin eine hass welle
gegen apple der kasper aus kassel macht
nicht mehr lange
möge der kerl bekommen was er verdient
reaktionen die auch walter lübke
beunruhigen hat wohl seine frau
angerufen und gesagt sie soll mit ihren
also mit den beiden söhnen zu verwandten
oder bekannten gehen dass hause erst mal
verlassen
ein schlüsselmoment für ernst in den
akten heißt es später bei der
bürgerversammlung sei ernst klar
geworden dass lübke ein volks schädling
sei der beseitigt werden müsse
wir wollen mehr erfahren wer ist stefan
ernst woher kommt sein hass gegen fremde
und vor allem warum konnte der mord an
walter lübke nicht verhindert werden
wir fahren nach hohenstein drei
autostunden von lohfelden entfernt hier
ist stefan ernst aufgewachsen
die radikalisierung des mutmaßlichen
mörders beginnt früh mit 15 jahren
zündet er ein wohnhaus an
sein motiv hass auf die dort lebenden
türken
er habe denen einen denkzettel geben
wollen
drei jahre später dann schon eine ganz
andere art von gewalt ein anschlag auf
bosnische flüchtlinge in einem
nachbarort mit einer selbst gebauten
bombe
der sprengsatz explodiert nicht die
heimbewohner können das feuer löschen
wir treffen adolf bremer er war damals
als polizist am tatort und vernahm
stefan ernst dem pensionierten ermittler
fällt das sprechen schwer
also schön ernst fasst vertrauen zu
polizist bremer und gesteht ihm später
nach einem weiteren mordversuch diesen
verübte er auf einer bahnhofstoilette in
wiesbaden
hier trifft er zufällig auf einen mann
der sieht aus wie ein ausländer ernst
stich zu in den rücken in die brust das
opfer ein türkischer imam kämpft
wochenlang um sein leben für das
landgericht wiesbaden ist der
messerangriff versuchter totschlag der
rohrbomben anschlag kein mordversuchen
sondern versuchte herbeiführung einer
sprengstoffexplosion
das gericht verurteilt stefan ernst zu
sechs jahren haft wertet seinen
charakter als strafmildernd
er sei in seiner steuerungsfähigkeit
erheblich beeinträchtigt gewesen habe
eine borderline persönlichkeitsstörung
und eine schwere andere seelische
abartigkeit das in der
gerichtsentscheidung stefan ernst
attestiert wird bei dass er seelisch
apathisch sei in früher jugend da das
zeigt ja offensichtlich dazu sagen dass
er wie eine tickende zeitbombe
schon damals eingeschätzt wurde
was ich ja leider jetzt auch bestätigt
hat
hätten die sicherheitsbehörden den
mutmaßlichen täter schon früher stoppen
können mit dieser frage wird sich der
untersuchungsausschuss im hessischen
landtag zum mordfall lübke beschäftigen
zur gleichen zeit als stefan ernst einen
imam in der bahnhofstoilette
niedersticht engagiert sich walter lübke
1992 in thüringen als politiker in der
jugendarbeit lübke veranstaltet konzerte
rock gegen gewalt die konzert
wochenenden richten sich auch gegen die
örtliche neonazi-szene lübke sei immer
ein kämpfer für die grundrechte gewesen
sagen wegbegleiter die verfassung die
grundrechte die freiheit in deutschland
das war für ihn was ganz ganz
wesentliches das hat ihn geprägt das hat
seine haltung immer bestimmt und dazu
gehört auch meinungsfreiheit also auch
eine andere meinung zu haben als die die
mainstream meinung dirigieren das war
für ihn völlig klar
1999 kehrte lücke von thüringen zurück
nach hessen
er wird in den hessischen landtag
gewählt im selben jahr kommt stefan
ernst nach sechs jahren haft frei er
findet sofort anschluss an die kasseler
neonazi szene
das berichten antifaschisten die sich
seit jahren mit den rechtsextremen
strukturen in hessen beschäftigen
sie wollen nicht erkannt werden stefan
ernst einem umfeld verkehrt wo sich ein
breites spektrum wieder gefunden hat ist
gar person aus der kameradschaftsszene
das gab personen aus der hooliganszene
npd führungskader mit dabei sind
personen aus dem kompletten spektrum aus
dem rockermilieu hsv hooligans eine
ganze bandbreite in dieser szene lernt
stefan ernst seinen späteren mittäter
markus haar kennen der auch das
youtube-video von lüpke hochlud die
bundesanwaltschaft wirft markus h vor
ernst bei seinem mordplan unterstützt zu
haben
und hat ihn wegen beihilfe zum mord
angeklagt markus habe gesagt dass walter
lübke verhängt werden müsse laut
ermittlungsakten verherrlicht markus
hardy nationalsozialismus und ist ein
waffennarr stefan ernst und markus h
fallenden behörden wiederholt auf so
auch 2009 am ersten mal werden beide
zusammen mit 400 anderen rechtsradikalen
wegen gewalttaten auf einer dgb
kundgebung in dortmund festgenommen
der hessische verfassungsschutz hält sie
für gefährlich
wir haben dort ein dokument vorgefunden
dass ein dossier war über mehrere
besonders militante neonazis aus
nordhessen und da war stefan ernst mit
aufgeführt
im übrigen auch sein kumpel markus h und
bei stefan ernst gab es eine
handschriftliche randbemerkung da der
sei brandgefährlich
der hessische verfassungsschutz
beobachtet ernst bis 2009 auf
zahlreichen rechtsextremistischen
versammlungen den ermittlern im mordfall
lübke erzählt der mutmaßliche mörder
ernst er habe sie spätestens 2011 aus
der szene gelöst
2011 wird die mord serie des
nationalsozialistischen untergrundes
bekannt auch in kassel hatten uwe mundt
loos und uwe böhm hat gemordet den
internet café betreiber harley die
oscars richteten sie per kopfschuss hin
zur aufklärung der nsu morde während
damals erkenntnisse über die kasseler
nazi-szene hilfreich gewesen doch der
hessische verfassungsschutz kann wenig
beitragen denn akten zur regionalen
neonazi-szene würden gelöscht oder sind
gesperrt
da stehen dann so sachen drin wie zb wir
finden über 500 aktenstücke nicht mehr
mit nsu beziehungsweise neonazi bezügen
im landesamt für verfassungsschutz
selbst ja vielleicht sind die auch
geschreddert worden also auf jeden fall
konnte diese behörde ihre aufgabe nicht
wahrnehmen nämlich uns vor
rechtsextremen terroristen zu schützen
dezember 2015 im hessischen nsu
untersuchungsausschuss wird ein
verfassungsschutz beamte hinzu stefan
ernst befragt sie sagt dessen akte sei
gelöscht oder gesperrt so kann sie nicht
erklären warum der geheimdienst stefan
ernst nach 2009 einen abgekühlten
neonazi nennt und deshalb nicht mehr
beobachtet was unsere nicht bekannt war
zum damaligen zeitpunkt war dass es per
so eine personenakte im
verfassungsschutz über stefan ernst
gegeben hat die just zu diesem zeitpunkt
als wir ihr nachgefragt haben im jahre
2015 dann auch intern gelöscht wurde
also nicht mehr zugänglich war für
keinen mitarbeiter im verfassungsschutz
seien bundesweit der verfassungsschutz
ordnete an die berichte über
rechtsextreme als verschlusssachen
einzustufen so wurde die geheimhaltungs
frist auf 30 jahre festgelegt warum hält
der verfassungsschutz die akten zu
stefan ernst und markus h jahrzehntelang
geheim waren die kasseler neonazis
v-leute
das haben die behörden klar dementiert
nach frontal recherchen trafen sich 1998
mitarbeiter des verfassungsschutzes drei
stunden lang mit markus hna in kassel
sie wollen haar als spitzel anwerben
doch der sagte nein
wir besuchen einen schießplatz nördlich
von kassel hier trainierte markus hahn
mit waffen haben sie den arzt mal selber
gesehen hier
die anklage wirft markus haar vor durch
die schießübungen habe er ernst in
seinem ort plänen bestärkt doch warum
durften zwei rechtsradikale überhaupt
mit waffen hantieren
die antwort überrascht
markus h erstritt sich 2015 vor gericht
eine waffenbesitzkarte
obwohl ordnungsamt und verfassungsschutz
bedenken hatten
die ehemalige lebensgefährtin von markus
habe schreibt ihm laut akten als gefühls
losen neonazi und sagt sein motto war
wir deutschen brauchen waffen
laut anklage hantierte er sogar mit
sprengstoff er habe diesen selber
hergestellt und probe sprengungen
durchgeführt
über einen kontakt von markus h soll
stefan ernst und später auch an die
mordwaffe gekommen sein
wir finden den mutmaßlichen
waffenhändler
würde ich würde es verstehen wie hat die
piste ernst und wir sind sie
zusammengekommen
zweimal hatte immer vertrauen in zehn
jahren kann ich nur eins ich habe ihn
kennengelernt total relaxt niemals
schaum vom mund ganz ruhig ich glaub mir
heute keiner was ist so malloth
bestreitet die tatwaffe besorgt zu haben
doch gegen ihn läuft deshalb ein
separates strafverfahren
zurück nach lohfelden nach der
einwohnerversammlung auf der das
folgenschwere video entstand wurden 800
asylsuchende in einem ehemaligen garten
center untergebracht
ganz in der nähe der wohnung von stefan
ernst sechster januar 2016 am abend
verlässt der iraker ahmad edesheim um
zigaretten zu holen ein mann nähert sich
mit dem fahrrad und sticht ihn mit einem
messer nieder
der täter ist nach ansicht der
bundesanwaltschaft stefan ernst ahmad
überlebt sagt später gegenüber der
polizei aus er hat mich gestochen und
hat dann mit dem fuß nach mehr getreten
so dass ich nicht vor ihm falle sondern
zur seite ich habe mehrfach versucht
hochzukommen habe es jedoch nicht
geschafft
ich fühlte mich wie gelähmt ahmad e
weist die ermittler mehrfach auf einem
möglichen rechtsextremen täter hin
doch ohne folgen nach meinen bisherigen
stand hat man keine ermittlungen in
richtung rassistischer tathintergrund
bzw nazi szene gemacht jedenfalls aus
dem teil der akten die ich bisher
gesehen habe ergibt sich das nicht
obwohl mein mandant sehr sehr vorsichtig
aber doch klar mehrfach auf diese
möglichkeit hingewiesen hat mai 2018
bewaffnet mit seinem revolver spät
stefan ernst erneut lüpkes wohnhaus aus
immer wieder lauert er dem
regierungspräsidenten auf um ihn zu
töten
er bereitet sich gewissenhaft auf den
anschlag vor arbeitet vorsichtsregeln
aus lange kontrolle und beobachtung des
tatorts vor der tatausführung an
tatwaffen dürfen keine haare oder
textilfasern haften weder von dir noch
vom opfer
was brauche ich ein material tatwerkzeug
und waffen eventuell pistole oder
schrotflinte und nachtsichtgerät er hat
sich darauf vorbereitet das war keine
spontane tat sondern das war eine
geplante über viele viele monate hin
konkret geplante mordaktion
erst der september 2018 9 monate vor dem
mordanschlag der sogenannte trauermarsch
der afg in chemnitz in der stadt war
zuvor ein mann niedergestochen worden
von einem asylbewerber in chemnitz
marschieren stefan ernst und markus h
gemeinsam mit anderen rechtsradikalen
ich denke schon dass bei der
radikalisierung von stefan ernst
die thüringer afd und insbesondere die
ecke eine ganz entscheidende rolle
spielen denn er hat sich ja immer so zu
sagen da dort hingezogen gefühlt nicht
nur durch die spenden sondern auch durch
die teilnahme an demonstrationen erster
juni 2009 10 kurz vor mitternacht jahre
lang hat stefan ernst mordpläne gegen
lübke geschmiedet und niemand hat ihn
daran gehindert sich zu bewaffnen
mindestens drei mal zuvor war stefan
ernst schon am wohnhaus von walter lübke
jetzt ist es soweit stefan ernst schießt
weiter lücke ohne vorwarnung aus einem
revolver in den kopf so die anklage der
bundesanwaltschaft der
regierungspräsident erliegt seiner
schweren kopfverletzung da kamen sofort
die erinnerung auch wieder hoch hier an
die bürgerversammlung in lohfelden und
dann habe ich noch auf facebook
sinngemäß gepostet vor vier jahren hat
er polizeischutz gehabt da es nicht
passiert und jetzt das also ich hab
intuitiv eine eine verbindung
hergestellt
bis heute sieht das video der
mutmaßlichen täter im netz hass
kommentare inklusive ich werde aber
nicht aufhören dafür zu kämpfen dass
genau solche dinge dann eben auch
ausgenommen werden und dass die opfer
von videos die ja auch immer noch die
die leben und die davon betroffen sind
dass die eben nicht weiter geschädigt
werden dadurch dass im netz diese videos
weiter vorhanden sind es geht um
opferschutz
der mutmaßliche mörder muss sich vor
gericht verantworten
stefan ernst bestreitet die tat hat sein
geständnis widerrufen
schiebt die schuld auf seinen kumpanen
marcus h der schuss sei nur aus versehen
losgegangen
die bundesanwaltschaft glaubt das nicht
[Musik]
in kassel trauern sie um einen politiker
mit rückgrat der die offene gesellschaft
verteidigte
[Musik]
rechter terror unterschätzen die
deutschen sicherheitsbehörden die gefahr
schreibt uns in die kommentare